- How did you come up
with the title of your
book, "Mixed Plate,"
How did you come up with that?
- Uh Mixed Plate, it's just like, okay.
One, I'm in love with Hawaii.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? Hawaii
really embraced me right away
when my first special came out,
I broke a record in Hawaii.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I got like my own day in Hawaii.
I sold like 27,000 tickets
at this theater called
the Blaisdell theater.
I broke Mariah Carey's record.
- What?
- Yeah.
It was like the most tickets ever sold,
and I gave it my own day.
And I just love the culture there.
I love the people there.
And one of the things I love, you know,
to eat was the mixed plate.
And when you look at the
mixed plate it has everything.
Like every ethnicity is on the plate.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There's a little rice for Asians,
there's Korean barbecue,
there's tempura, Japanese,
there's spam on it,
there's mac salad.
So when you look at that
plate, I think of me.
It's like a little bit
of all these cultures
just mixed up into me.
And I just felt like that's
a good representation
of what this book is and
about my life in this world.
- That's a beautiful way
to look at the world.
- Yeah, 'cause you put all
that stuff on one plate
and it just becomes this
beautiful plate of food.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I feel like that's
what it took to make-
- But I just mean, it's society.
- It's cool-
- - [Jo Koy] Yeah.
- to look at the world like that.
- [Jo Koy] Yeah.
- Like we all count,
we all matter,
we all make the plate beautiful.
- Yeah, you put it all-
- Even spam.
Even redneck spam.
Put spam next to a filet mignon.
You know what?
I'm eating that spam.
- Fine, it's fancier.
Tastes better already.